parts of Peru's history have returned
home sculptures textiles Ceramics and
other works of indigenous art some of
them more than 2,000 years old they tell
the story of a time before the Spanish
Conquest lithic elements such as the
club heads and sculptures are typical in
the incor culture there are also various
instruments and textile fragments
belonging into the Shanghai culture a
piece of metal with shimu cultural
affiliation there is also a group of
ceramic pieces from the mo nesa lambay
Inca and other cultural
Styles some of the items were smuggled
out of the country illegally others have
been held in museums or by private
collectors most were handed back to Peru
voluntarily but not
all more than 40 pieces were seized by
the United States Department of Homeland
Security and the German police which
unfortunately proves the importance of
further strengthening International
cooperation to combat trafficking of
cultural property around the
world Peru has repatriated 840 looted
Antiquities over the past 2 years it's
seen as a success as indigenous
communities worldwide reckon with the
colonial past and campaign for the
return of stolen artifacts ipam gfood Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer